c'est la petite goutte celle qui a
tendance à finir dans le slip et ben on
va apprendre à s'en débarrasser alors
oui ça concerne plutôt les gens qui
possèdent un pénis mais si vous en avez
dans votre entourage vous pourrez leur
expliquer la petite doute quand vous
avez fini elle reste coincée dans
l'urètre là au niveau de la flèche rouge
parce que vous avez vu ça fait un coude
et quand vous relâchez tout bas ça se
vide comme un tuyau d'arrosage donc vous
comprenez bien que ça sert à rien de
secouer votre truc dans tous les sens
pour la faire partir là elle est trop
loin la petite goutte ce qu'il faut
faire c'est appuyer avec votre pouce là
où il y a la flèche bleue
entre les roubignols et le et puis vous
poussez vers l'avant pour l'expulser oui
et après vous vous lavez les mains je
vais pas vous dire je suis pas votre
mère en tout cas faites le test vous
verrez ça marche le nombre de flip est
dignité que je vais sauver moi si je
pouvais je me donne une médaille